le procès des quatre profanateurs du
cimetière juif de carpentras s'est
ouvert ce matin à marseille vous haïr
les rebelles entend bien obligé le
président mobutu à quitter le pouvoir
d'ici s est de nouveau hospitalisé en
france luc alphand champion du monde de
ski toutes catégories il rejoint dans la
légende
jean claude killy quatre années de
tournées dans le monde entier quatre ans
ont enregistré
patricia kaas est notre invité ce soir
avec son nouvel album qui sort demain
simultanément dans 44 pays
madame monsieur bonsoir devant la cour
d'assises de nice ce matin s'est ouvert
le procès d'un fait divers tragique
un vétérinaire de 48 ans jean louis
turcat est accusé de l'assassinât de son
fils de 7 ans cet assassinat serait le
résultat d'une vengeance entre les deux
époux le père nie les faits le corps de
l'enfant n'a jamais été retrouvé yasmina
farber il est bon sur un image de
jean-louis turquin dans le box des
accusés c'est l'image qu'il donnait
qu'il ya six ans aux enquêteurs ce matin
du 21 mars 91 le vétérinaire appelle le
commissariat
charles-edouard son fils de 7 ans a
disparu alors qu'il dormait dans un lit
jumeau à ses côtés à la barre le
directeur de l' enquête de la brigade
des mineurs précise le contexte familial
madame turquin a quitté le domicile
conjugal
le couple est en procédure de divorce
jean-louis turquin ce doute qui n'est
pas le père biologique de l'enfant sur
le banc des parties civiles michel
ballanger l'ex épouse de jean-louis
turquin une femme d'alluré fragile qui
va siéger sous marine enregistrée à son
insu
il avoue avoir étranglé charles-edouard
avant de l'enterrer sur les hauteurs de
nice vers des moments où on arrive à de
pareils aux aveux
on ne peut considérer qu'ils sont le
reflet de la réalité donc l année
persuadé mais il ya un certain nombre
d'offres aux trois éléments qui font que
pour elle cet enfant est définitivement
perdue en dehors des aveux sur bandes
magnétiques jean-louis turquin a
toujours nié l'assassinât
à la barre le vétérinaire s'est décrit
sentimentale timide et froid en
apparence il a dit encore aimer sa femme
malgré ses nombreux amants la loire a
compris que ce mars que là mais qu'une
protection il est profondément est
bouleversée et très ému on l'a vu michel
ballanger elle va parfois faire tomber
le masque
les experts psychiatriques ont peut être
donné une des clés du procès selon eux
le couple vivait dans un schéma
sadomasochistes où l'enfant n'avait pas
sa place
un grand déballage les débats nous font
entrer dans l'intimité des écoutes urcun
un procès psychologique de l'accusé mais
aussi de sa femme
à force d'évoquer vos relations
tumultueuses ce couple on oublierait
presque la disparition de leur enfant de
7 ans dont le corps n'a jamais été
retrouvé
c'est à marseille maintenant six ans
dans quête sans résultat et enfin en
juillet 96 la justice retrouve les
profanateurs du cimetière juif de
carpentras encore fallait-il que l'un
d'entre eux pris de remords se rende à
la police
aujourd'hui ils sont quatre dans le box
des accusés du tribunal de marseille
ils reconnaissent que cet acte odieux
leur avait été inspiré par des idées
d'extrême droite balayée remis au
ministère presque sept ans que madeleine
germond attendaient ce moment là sept
ans que la veuve des félix germans
attendait de mettre un visage sur les
propagateurs de la tombe de félix son
mari c'est des grands pulls ccsdn des
cils ce je ne sais pas et il n'y a pas
de l'homme
les hommes sont capables de les tirer en
mort il faut le faire hein
madeleine germond a bien souvent réagi
dans la salle aux propos des quatre
profanateurs nous formions un groupe de
yannick garnier garnier qui s'étaient
dénoncés à la police en juillet dernier
un groupe poursuit-il fasciné par
l'ordre établi l'apologie de la race
blanche et la haine de l'étranger
oui nous admirions à la politique
d'adolphe hitler
mais aujourd'hui j'ai changé et je suis
fier d'avoir fait c'est à vous j'en ai
la chair de poule
je frémis vint le tour d'olivier fin
brille le militaire dans votre caserne
on a retrouvé des affiches nazi lui dit
la présidente que représente pour vous
qui est militaire la waffen ss la waffen
ss répond-t-il eh bien c'était l'élite
vous avez des notions d'histoire très
particulière lui rétorque que le
tribunal
depuis 55 eur l'extrême droite en france
c'est la volonté de prendre la revanche
sur les juifs les francs-maçons
l'anti-france les gaullistes et la
république
et là on à malibu pro sionistes à leurs
déclarations les quelques romans ou
regret énoncé à l'audience n'ont pas
franchement convaincu
madeleine germain sur place à marseille
dominique verdeilhan dominique bonsoir
ce procès est très attendu mais
rappelons qu'il se déroule devant un
tribunal correctionnel
et que finalement les peines encourues
sont minimes ce qui va décevoir beaucoup
de beaucoup de gens oui mais l'enjeu de
ce procès dépasse les éventuelles
condamnations
d'un côté on a quatre prévenus pour qui
cette profanation n'est qu'un fait
divers il parle d'ailleurs d'une grosse
bêtise il c'est tout juste s'il ne
perdrait pas ses erreurs de jeunesse de
l'autre et bien c'est la vraie dimension
de ce procès quatre personnalités lâche
pâlotte vulnérables fragiles face à un
discours politique puis-je attirante le
front national a parasité ma pensée dit
l'un les idées les discours de l'extrême
droite me sont montées à la tête concède
un autre conséquence vous le savez donc
la haine de l'autre
d'où un un décalage effectivement face à
l'émotion face au dégoût provoqué par la
profanation de carpentras
la réponse judiciaire peut paraître
minime peine maximale prévue deux ans de
prison
volonté ici à marseille eh bien on ne
juge pas simplement quatre hommes et de
faire le procès d'une idéologie
merci dominique deuxième grande
conférence sur la famille à l'hôtel
matignon en ce moment même encore pour
l'instant la principale décision
concernerait l'allongement de la
prestation d'allocations familiales de
18 à 19 ans pour les enfants à charge
sans emploi elle ne concernerait que les
familles nombreuses de plus de trois
enfants dont la nièce molinié la lutte
va chauffer question et son style autres
ministres syndicalistes et responsables
d'associations familiales ont planché
tout l'après-midi sur la famille
résultat plusieurs propositions sont
faites par le gouvernement
oui d'abord l'allongement des
allocations familiales jusqu'à 19 ans au
lieu de 18 pour les enfants à charge qui
ne font pas d'études uniquement dans
l'est vraiment nombreux en suisse
la réforme du congé parental pourrait
être pris à n'importe quel moment
jusqu'au saison de l'enfant et de façon
fractionnée
enfin un temps partiel scolaire serait
possible les parts on pourrait étaler la
réduction de leur temps de travail sur
l'année pour pouvoir être en vacances en
même temps que leurs enfants
aujourd'hui nous avons essayé de tracer
des perspectives d'avenir avec bien sûr
et je les dis sans fard une contrainte
budgétaire que chacun connaît l'ancien
coûterait 500 millions de francs prise
en charge dans le budget de la sécurité
sociale pour des saint-jacques non
distribuer des cacahuètes en espérant
qu'ils diront merci
non c'est pas sérieux une marche en
avant lente trop longtemps notre goût
mais que faire de mieux que de se battre
aux avants ce qu un débat d'orientation
sur la politique familiale est prévue
pour la prochaine session parlementaire
ce problème d'allocation familiale
intéresse au premier chef les familles
qui ont plusieurs enfants et notamment
celle est qui les poussent à poursuivre
des études supérieures apparemment elles
ne seront donc pas concernée par les
mesures qui seront prises elisabeth
eisele berlin arabe et même en l'absence
du père c'est une famille nombreuse
comme ceux qui ont au moins trois
enfants
lee berger perçoivent des prestations et
des aides spécifiques
ils ont quatre enfants à charge
maryse interlope benoît avant claude 18
ans leschi 12 ans ce sont les aînés qui
de loin coûte le plus cher aux parents
surtout depuis qu'ils ont 20 ans plus
d'allocations familiales pour eux
l'obligation de cotiser individuellement
à la sécurité sociale et perte de la
carte famille nombreuse pour tous marie
aline berger a fait ses comptes
en 18 mois on a perdu 1 4800 francs de
pouvoir d'achat par mois marie est en
troisième année de droit
benoît en deuxième année de prépa
scientifique les études leur laisse peu
de temps pour des petits boulots
difficile d'aider les parents j'essaie
de travailler un mois l'été donc pendant
les premiers mois de l'année je vis avec
mes soul était pâle pas entièrement mais
un petit peu quand j'essaye de leur
hôtel moins cher possible
et puis et puis après c'est une finance
mes vêtements ma nourriture les bergers
voudrait toucher des prestations
familiales au moins jusqu'au 22 ans de
leurs enfants parce que les études sont
de plus en plus longue parce que les
jeunes restent de plus en plus longtemps
chez leurs parents leur souhait n'a pas
été entendu les allocations familiales
vont être prolongées mais seulement pour
les jeunes qui ne poursuivent pas
d'étude attentat ce matin à bruxelles un
cocktail molotov a été lancé contre un
café pour le coup un incendie qui s'est
propagé à tout l'immeuble
quatre personnes ont été tuées et cinq
autres blessées cinq suspects ont été
arrêtés il pourrait s'agir d'un
règlement de comptes le café est
inconnue pour servir de rendez-vous à
des pratiquants drogue quatre morts et
une trentaine de blessés selon la spa
alger cet après midi trois voitures
piégées ont explosé en plein centre
ville
un autre attentat ce matin qui n'a pas
fait de blessé heureusement très tôt
dans une mosquée de la rue de tanger
dans le 19e arrondissement de paris
un engin explosif a principalement
dommages et la porte d'entrée
l'engin avait été dissimulée dans un
extincteur plusieurs pistes s'offrent
aux enquêteurs vincent guyenne michel
levasseur
de la porte de la mosquée adawa il ne
reste rien aux dires des enquêteurs
c'est un extincteur piégée qui a explosé
juste devant à 4h30 ce matin pas une
vitre de l'immeuble d'en face n'a
résisté à la déflagration mais à part le
gardien légèrement blessé il n'y a pas
eu de victime pas de victimes
à une demi heure près 6 heures à la
radio
oui c'est l'heure des prières et
quelques heures plus tard l'école juste
à côté ouvrait ses portes ce matin
fidèle des voisins afficher leur stupeur
certains même lancé quelques accusations
hâtives le front national a soutenu il
est vrai manifestations et pétitions
contre un projet d'agrandissement de la
mosquée qui devait prochainement aboutir
mais il est bien tôt pour incriminer qui
que ce soit et le maître des lieux veut
avant tout calmé les esprits
à la relance
bien qu assigné à résidence à folembray
en 95
ce recteur est considéré par beaucoup
comme un modéré il a d'ailleurs dénoncé
ici même l'assassinât des sept moines de
tibérine c'est peut-être son discours
ouvert et tolérant qui était la cible
des poseurs de bombes
les enquêteurs n'excluent pas cette
hypothèse
les ouvriers de renault vilvoorde en
belgique ont décidé de poursuivre la
grève décision prise ce matin de son
côté renault réaffirme que la fermeture
et les tue est inévitable en juillet et
le président d'entreprise wilfred l'air
s'apprête à rencontrer mercredi les
syndicats lice ce soir je vous signale
dans sept à suivre ce côtes sérillon
nous proposera une émission spéciale
consacrée justement au conflit de
renault belgique en albanie le président
berisha cherche par tous les moyens à
convaincre les albanais et l'opinion
publique internationale qu'il reprend
les choses en main il a demandé aux
fonctionnaires de se remettre au travail
police et armée sont également très
présentes dans les rues de la capitale
tirana ses fans mais elle est bien
visible
la police albanaise à bord de ses chats
elle veut montrer à tout prix que la
situation se normalise si possible grâce
à l'action du président berisha alors on
rafistole les dégâts causés par les
pillards on trouvera quelques magasins
et on annonce à rentrer dans les écoles
les universités pour les prochains jours
et le président albanais va devoir
rendre des comptes
l'homme qui désormais apparaît comme le
plus apte à rassembler le pays derrière
lui le voici fatos nano leader de
l'opposition libéré de prison hier soir
favori des élections prévues en juin
prochain ce sera un interlocuteur
incontournable pour la mission de
l'union européenne qui est arrivé cet
après midi à tirana pour évaluer les
besoins de l'albanie mais pas question
d'envoyer une force quelconque
d'interposition les albanais devront
résoudre eux mêmes le problème des armes
volées
près de 5000 armes lourdes ont été
saisis ont rendu mais il en resterait
près de 100 fois plus en circulation
et ce ne sera pas facile comme en
témoigne cette scène elle se déroule
dans le port de new rech des réfugiés
essayent d'embarquer pour l'italie
la mafia albanaise se payer le passage
entre 3000 et 5000 francs et parfois
elle s'énerve cette fusillade là
n'auraient pas fait de victimes les à
jirau casters la banque aurait été
dévalisés dans une autre ville a requis
une visite similaire aurait fait quatre
morts
effectivement le flux des réfugiés
albanais ne s'est toujours pas tari
aujourd'hui 5600 réfugiés ont débarqué
sur les côtes italiennes
et ce matin encore ils étaient 1400
femmes hommes enfants à vouloir débarqué
dans le port italien de braine dit où
les autorités italiennes font savoir
qu'elles ne sont plus en mesure
d'accueillir le moindre nouveaux
réfugiés sur place alain job 15h cet
après midi le pana yacht pape apparaît
au large des côtes de brindilles encadré
par deux vedettes italiennes ce bateau
de pêche a été signalée quittant le port
de vlora en albanie vers 7h ce matin en
direction de l'italie
à son bord 250 personnes environ
beaucoup de femmes et d'enfants fuyant
l'anarchie albanaise à la recherche d'un
hypothétique mieux-être de ce côté-ci de
l'adriatique
pour eux le port de brindilles si c'est
un peu l'entrée de la terre promise
à l'arrivée le comité d'accueil
policiers marins douaniers personnels de
santé commence à être rodé depuis quatre
jours des bateaux comme le pana iode
papa ils en ont vu arriver quelques
dizaines avec environ 5000 réfugiés les
hommes et les bagages sont soigneusement
fouillés il y a tellement d'armes en
circulation en albanie le bateau va être
aussi passé au peigne fin
toujours les armes mais aussi la drogue
spécialité de la mafia albanaise
les autorités des migrations vont
ensuite procédé à l'amant câble le
regroupement des femmes et des enfants
d'un côté des hommes de l'autre
opération humiliante mais que les
réfugiés par est acceptée avec
résignation
il fallait d'abord sortir de l'enfer et
des avants pas et puis il ya mon pain
noir
espérons qu ici nous pourrons trouver
des gens avec un un coeur gros comme ça
les réfugiés seront ensuite dirigés vers
un centre de transit ou leur cas va être
examiné individuellement
la plupart aura le droit de rester trois
mois
le commandant du bateau risque lui des
ennuis il n'a pas fui le pays mais fait
de l'argent tout l'argent que nous
avions nous n'avons donné pour le billet
de bateau un million de livres 1 3500
francs à 17h le pana yeux de papa était
déjà remarqué pour aller rejoindre de
l'autre côté du port les bateaux
albanais arrivés ces derniers jours et
surtout pour laisser la place aux
suivants
alors que dans son pays au zaïre les
rebelles entendent bien l'amener à
renoncer au pouvoir le président mobutu
actuellement en france vient d'être à
nouveau hospitalisé à monaco où les
rumeurs les plus contradictoires cours
sur son véritable état de santé
à la suite de sa récente opération d'un
cancer de la prostate
quoi qu'il en soit d'ailleurs vous haïr
on parie de moins en moins sur un
nouveau retour en force de celui qui
depuis plus de 30 ans maintenant incarne
le pouvoir absolu
isabelle qui a réalisé et édité
venez ces capteurs aux bretons qui vous
parle bien pacifier la lune ébranlable
maréchal même au coeur de la tourmente
il n'a jamais douté grand frère tu es le
meilleur ce qu'on la foule les ovations
sont bien rodés après trente ans de mots
boutique vous depuis sept ans le
maréchal s'est retirée ici akbar de lui
une retraite de luxe en plein jour à
1500 km de la capitale kinshasa
courtenay
la réalité c'est quoi en afrique
peux pas concevoir nos chefs d'état
soient malheureux qu'ils quémandent
saab allemagne auprès des citoyens on
n'a plus rien on n'a plus rien ils
famille par exemple
deux des cinq enfants au mans le zaïre
est en ruine alors que le sol regorge de
richesses
or et diamant le régime n'offrent à son
peuple que misère 1991 et 93 c'est la
révolte pillages émeutes en sanglant
kinshasa une partie de l'armée se
mutinent ici même les soldats sont
devenus voleurs mois pour moi aux abois
par deux mois dernier rempart d'une
forteresse qui vacille la garde
présidentielle elle reste fidèle
fort de ses unités d'élite
l'indétrônable maréchal règne depuis 30
ans mais répète inlassablement qu'il est
un démocrate paul et de chanter madame
la marquise tout va très bien j'ai
évolué et le changement c'est moi ne se
pressent que le seul départ au monde
bien qu'ils attendent toujours les
élections son peuple voulait encore
croire que le maréchal reprendrait en
main l'armée le pays
mais le vieux leopard est malade le
zaïre l'est encore plus l'avancée des
rebelles sonne comme la fin d'un règne
pour joseph désiré mobutu président
jacques chirac est arrivée à buenos
aires en argentine pour la dernière
étape de son voyage en amérique du sud
avec le brésil l'argentine et le moteur
économique de ce continent et jacques
chirac a donc repris à cette occasion ce
qu'il appelle lui-même salle valises
deux premiers représentants de commerce
de la france finit paroisse jean corne
mais n'osaient symbole du dynamisme
sud-américain avait sorti son apparat
pour la venue de jacques chirac
ici on aime la france on apprend le
français mais depuis l'an dernier n'est
plus obligatoire de l'ouche et aux
produits portugais
le géant brésilien n'est pas loin et
surtout de l'anglais car les états unis
sont omniprésents en argentine c'est la
puissance économique qui leur permettent
ça mais l'anglais qu'on nous apprend par
tous partout des femmes dispensable pour
gagner sa vie
vous savez n'est donc pas accès à une
culture le président carlos menem
c'est lui qui a lancé le tgv du
redressement économique en argentine
les résultats sont spectaculaires
dayraut % d'inflation en 96 contre 3000
il ya dix ans et le coût social et rue
18 % de chômage
et gare à l'explosion malgré tout
l'argentine continue à privatiser et à
s'ouvrir aux investisseurs étrangers
la france est présente avec total france
telecom la lyonnaise des eaux
edf et d'autre l'argentine est au coeur
la france est un des acteurs majeurs de
l'union européenne nous sommes bons fait
pour nous en tant que pour être le fer
de lance du rapprochement de nous deux
on sent qu'il est vrai que les états
unis considèrent l'argentine comme leur
pré carré
le pays s'ouvre à tous les investisseurs
étrangers et la france est bien installé
mais elle peut et doit mieux faire
c'est le message de jacques chirac ici à
beynost their l'occasion de ce séjour à
buenos aires nos reporters ont pu
constater combien à près de cinquante
ans après sa disparition l'ombre d'eva
peron dont on a récemment parlé à propos
d'un film où elle était interprétée par
madonna cette ombre est vraiment très
présent notamment dans les quartiers
pauvres où la belle dame comme on
l'appelait et met à venir réconforter
les familles ont portage dorothée
olliéric jean-françois
de l'autre côté du rio de la plata le
buenos aires tout en building celui du
miracle économique
mais ici ce ne sont plus que cargo
rouillé et maisons en tôle ondulée le
buenos aires des classes populaires
c'est dans ce quartier de la bocca plus
débarque un jour de 1935 celle qui
allait devenir la première dame
d'argentine
eva peron souvenirs pour les anciens et
vita est devenu un modèle pour les
jeunes
elle a survécu à toutes les modes tous
les coups d'état les idoles de
l'argentine surtout de notre quartier
ses perd 1,8 à évita malades
maradona et le che guevara et ma période
venait voir les gens qui viennent rien à
manger et qui ne pouvait pas étudier à 6
après elle trouvait toujours des
solutions pour les aider pour l'aider ce
qu'à nice et d'autres laissant chimiques
comme elle les appelait évita peron
avait inventé un idéal de justice
sociale elle donnait beaucoup aux plus
démunis même si finalement c'était la
gloire et l'argent que cherchait le
péronisme sera révolutionnaire ou ne
sera pas 10 et évite à la pasionaria
alors des argentins en manque deux
figures mythiques écrivent à
l'accablement sur les murs les
professions de foi de leur madone luc
ailleurs des habitants de l'agglo qu'à
vivre dans le souvenir de la grande dame
ce jour là ne tombent tous et pour eux
pas pour les touristes
nous avons tellement bien et là c'est
comme moi ma visite a été adulé par les
uns et détesté par les autres est là
parce que sa personnalité était très en
pointe et donne énormément et ce qu'elle
n'aimait pas ou qui les a pas d'accord
dit non elle est née travers voix contre
106 des 45 ans après sa mort évite est
toujours dans le coeur d argent elle est
même plus qu'une légende pour ces jeunes
des quartiers défavorisés qui n'ont
aujourd'hui que le fou et la musique
pour oublier le chômage le premier
ministre john major s'est décidée
n'avait plus beaucoup de temps
d'ailleurs les élections initiative en
angleterre auront lieu le 1er mai
prochain pour l'instant les
travaillistes sont largement favori
devant les conservateurs de john mais
jobs lui mois après le meurtre de la
jeune caroline dickinson 13 en voyage à
pleine fougères en bretagne son père
remettent en cause le travail des
enquêteurs français sur place à londres
etienne et on la première fois ce matin
depuis la disparition de leur vie
caroline john et suzanne dickinson ont
dit publiquement leur déception et leur
colère depuis huit mois ils attendent le
premier indice qui leur donnerait
l'espoir de voir l'assassin de leur fils
arrêté et envoyé en prison
on enquête n'a pas avancé on trouve les
autorités françaises
comprenez bien que nous ne resterons pas
sans rien faire des bras croisés à
attendre calmement telle enquête
progresse
caroline dickinson avait 13 ans en
juillet dernier elle avait été violée et
étranglée en pleine nuit dans le petit
village de pleine fougères où elle
passait ses vacances depuis l' enquête
piétine et le père de caroline accusé
pêle-mêle les gendarmes français de ne
pas se consacrer sérieusement à l'anc
est de ne pas être assez nombreux et il
a d'ores et déjà encouragé les parents
des écoles britanniques à ne pas envoyer
dans un an
en séjour en france l'été prochain dans
cette région la frustration et la colère
bien compréhensible des parents de
caroline dickinson sont régulièrement
relayées dans la presse britannique
les journaux ne manque pas une occasion
de rappeler que dans une autre affaire
le meurtre de céline figard sept jeunes
étudiantes françaises assassinées en
décembre 95 en grande bretagne le
coupable un chauffeur routier anglais
avait été arrêté deux mois plus tard
seulement grâce au travail méticuleux
d'une centaine d'enquêteurs britannique
la comparaison on l'aura compris ne joue
pas en faveur des gendarmes français
la pollution atmosphérique a encore fait
la une de l'actualité ces derniers jours
et ne doit pas nous faire oublier à un
grand chantier engagé celui du nettoyage
de tous les bâtiments dans lesquels
l'amiante a été utilisé ces trente
dernières années 100 millions de mètres
carrés serait à nettoyer ces travaux
gigantesques ont obligés à la création
d'entreprises spécialisées
reste un problème qui n'est pas
entièrement réglé loin de là celui du
stockage des déchets dangereux
votre enquête de ce soir venez par
valérie gas j'ai fini de la fa est
intitulé déchets à prendre avec des
gants et qui sait comme pour une guerre
chimique
ces hommes se protège d'un ennemi
invisible l'amiante contenue dans les
dalles de cet ancien supermarché situé
tout près de vous bourre à paris
l'arrosage sert à plaquer au sol les
fibres d'amiante un poison hautement
cancérigène
d'autres ouvriers s'apprête à gratter le
plafond lui aussi est entièrement floqué
à l'amiante
le chantier va durer trois mois et le
désamianteurs sait déjà qu'il va
produire une grosse quantité de déchets
toxiques
nous avons trois mille huit cents mètres
carrés de dalles vinyle amiante soit
environ 20 tonnes et 3300 mètres carrés
de blocage soit environ 22 tonnes tous
les déchets amiantés doivent être
emballées dans un premier sac qui est
lavé dans un sas de décontamination
ce sac est ensuite placé dans une
deuxième enveloppe marqués du logo
amiante tous les déchets sont finalement
regroupés dans un gros sac de
manutention appelée big bag
seules les sociétés habilitées à
transporter des matières dangereuses
peuvent prendre en charge ce type de
cargaison
le risque majeur est l'accident avec
dispersion des fibres d'amiante dans
l'atmosphère nous sommes ne l'oublions
pas un maillon de la chaîne du
désamiantage
nous allons donc vérifier d'abord si le
conditionnement est légal et répondent
aux prescriptions anciens big bag par
exemple de conditionnement est ouvert
nous le prendrons pas
en région parisienne la majeure partie
des déchets amiantés rejoint le centre
de stockage de villeparisis
ici les big bag sont déposées dans des
alvéoles étanche composé d'argile
le propriétaire des locaux des amiantés
et 2000 francs pour chaque tonne
entreposés c'est le centre de stockage
qui devient alors responsable de ces
déchets les sacs que nous apercevons
derrière vont être recouverts par une
pellicule de terre ou de sable on est
donc ce ce qui est ici va devenir ce que
nous avons ici qui correspond à ce que
nous avons reçus pendant les semaines
précédentes ils sont enfuis a dit ils
sont enfouis à vie mais l'enfouissement
n'est pas l'unique porte de sortie car
on peut aussi éliminer les déchets
amiantés en les chauffant 1600 degrés
lusine inertam filiale d'eads et f
installé dans les landes est la seule à
utiliser ce procédé venue de
l'aérospatiale
la coulée obtenu à la sortie du four ne
présente plus aucun danger
après refroidissement elle forme des
sortes de cahiers inerte qui peuvent
être réutilisés par exemple pour la
construction de routes
seul problème inertage coûte trois fois
plus cher que l'enfouissement
pour le coup à l'heure actuelle varie
entre 5000 et 6000 francs la tonne selon
les quantités ceux qui demandent plus
cher que l'enfouissement technique mais
ceci est est logique puisque dans un
camp détruit la fibre dans l'autre
cornes détruit pas la fribourg ne fait
que la stocker dans un trou la france
compte 11 centres de stockage de classe
1 et une seule usine d' inertage basée à
mortain mais tous les déchets amiantés
n'arrive pas dans ces sites agréés
exemple les déchets des particuliers
faute de collecte de nombreux objets
contenant de l'amiante comme les gants
de cuisine ou les grippes 1 partent avec
les poubelles autre exemple les déchets
de chantier l'amiante sous forme de
flocage ou de fibrociment et mélanger
aux autres gravats malgré la
réglementation tout danger de
vagabondage des déchets amiantés n'est
donc pas encore écartée
le sport luc alphand vainqueur de la
coupe du monde de ski toutes catégories
de rentrer dans la légende des meilleurs
skieurs sol avant lui en france jean
fauque lui avait réussi une telle
performance c'était il ya 29 ans ray
exactement et une marseillaise très
attendu par l'ue 15 demain son nouvel
album intitulé dans ma chair sortira
simultanément dans 44 pays
patricia kaas qui est devenu une star
internationale n'avait pas enregistré
depuis quatre ans maintenant et depuis
beaucoup de choses des lois ont changé
ricardo
je me rends
une ville mythique pour décor des
auteurs compositeurs tels que jean
jacques goldman
le tout pour servir sa voix le retour de
patricia kaas s'annonce à la hauteur de
ses dernières apparitions tout
simplement comme un événement
m
tous
mais
tiens tiens
dix ans après mademoiselle chante le
blues la jeune fille timide de forbach
est désormais une artiste internationale
avec plus de deux millions et demi
d'albums vendus hors de france
les appels lancés son nouveau disque
français patricia kaas se prépare déjà
pour un défi la sortie de son premier
disque en anglais aux états unis bref
les occasions de prendre le temps de
s'asseoir pour la jeune femme de 30 ans
s'annonce plutôt rare
non
le temps
jackass bonsoir et merci d'avoir réservé
cette visite à notre journal alors on va
tout de suite parlé de la nouvelle
patricia kaas l'album ça avant par les
instants on va parler également tout de
suite du nouveau look puisque vous
faites la une de tous les magazines qui
soit femina ou même les magazines
d'information alors ça correspond à quoi
ce changement ça correspond à plein de
choses ça correspond à un changement de
vie parce que quand on a 30 ans 20 ans
en ce sens différemment et puis je sais
pas il ya deux ans j'avais je sais pas
j'avais envie j'ai en fait à un magazine
j'ai vu une fille et des cheveux blonds
l'aide et je me suis dit j'essaye et
j'ai essayé j'ai aimé puis j'ai pas j'ai
pas voulu changer de look pour cet album
c'est à dire que j'ai pas voulu qu'il ya
un décalage entre l'artiste et le
personnage comme ça a pu l'être
auparavant parce qu'on passe par des
moments où on est un peu perdu on passe
par des moments où on cherche un peu et
là je crois que aujourd'hui je suis un
peu j'ai plus confiance en moi et je
suis plus moi-même
et donc voilà donc ce changement est lié
à 30 ans 1
j'ai pas tout ce qui s'est passé dans ma
vie plein de choses
en tout cas ça vous va très bien merci
alors parlons maintenant l'album qui est
très nouveau suis celui-là 13 titres
choisis au milieu de plusieurs centaines
de propositions vous avez fait une
musique notamment avec des auteurs comme
goldman barbelivien bergman et où
surtout une voix
j'ai écouté un peu différente - rock - -
dietrich comme vous le faisiez il ya
quelques années encore moi je m'en rend
un peu moins content parce que ce qui
habille et des chansons sur lesquelles
je donne plus de bouaye des chansons
effectivement il ya de plus de retenue
et ce qui se passe c'est que déjà je
sais mieux l'utiliser ces deux voies et
parce que je la connais mieux et ensuite
je les diriger sur cet album je sais que
on voit la pression justement vous
prenez les choses de plus en plus en
main vous aimez - quand vous dirigez
vous prenait vraiment votre votre
carrière en main parce que j'ai plus
d'expérience avance et pas qu'eux on me
laissait pas c'est qu'il y avait des
choses que je pouvais pas décider parce
que je connaissais pas
et aujourd'hui ben c'est vrai que je
m'implique de plus en plus et je me
rends compte que en fait on s'est mieux
ce qui est bien pour soi et on peut
mieux le faire quand on est soi mais
alors je ne vais plus faire de
comparaison comme certains avec des
lettres chanteuse parce que vous avez
passé le k ressembler à quelqu'un vous
n'êtes pas très grave cela dit vous avez
bien l'intention de faire une très
grande carrière notamment maintenant du
côté des états unis cet été vous
enregistré en anglais pourquoi cette
tentation des ethnies on ne peut pas
être une grande chanteuse uniquement ici
en europe il faut c'est un pari enfin
challenge
non je dirais que c'est c'est un rêve
mais c'est un rêve qu'on partage avec
qu'on peut pas réaliser seul et j'ai
senti ma maison disque américaine prête
prête à travailler pour une artiste
française et je veux dire c'est quand
même un pays qui est très loin et
sortent plein d'artistes tout le temps
et j'ai pris vraiment comme une chambre
c'est vous pouvez y arriver je sais pas
je il y avait ces voix là mais y avait
il y avait cette question qui était de
chanter en anglais donc j'ai dit écoutez
si on fait pas de moins quelqu'un
d'autre si je peux garder mes émotions
et le penser en france m
voilà et voilà et puis bon ben on va
foncer on va voir ce que ça donne alors
quatre ans enregistré cent enregistrée
mais avec des tournées dans le monde
entier notamment dans les pays de l'est
vous avez été très bien très bien
accueilli ce que vous aimez vous par
dessus tout c'est la scène parce que par
rapport à d'autres jeunes artistes vous
vous avez déjà une très longue
expérience et au moins dix ans de scène
avant d'enregistrer que ce soit oui j'ai
commencé par la scène j'ai commencé avec
le contact du public is a fait la
meilleure école parce que peu importe
quelle condition n'a pas peur et ça ça
aide quand même beaucoup mais je
connaisse ce sentiment même si à
l'époque ce n'était pas là une chose les
gens venaient pas forcément pour mouvoir
- est venu pour s'amuser pour rigoler
enfin pour danser et là je pourrai pas
sortir un album sans faire de ce
spectacle j'ai besoin du contact avec le
public et même si j'aime le studio c'est
important parce que on a même des choses
nouvelles
voilà alors vous avez à peine 30 ans
déjà 17 ans de carrière
est ce que peut encore vous parler de de
vos débuts est ce qu on peut évoquer vos
débuts est ce que vous y pensez encore
with an mais non
soir qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé un petit
pansement je pense souvent
est ce que vous avez envie de retour et
dans ce cabaret comment s'appelait-il
rôle polka morts ouais mais il existe ça
allez voir il et nous asseoir là-bas et
dire que j'en ai fait du chemin
mais j'y pense surtout bon comme comme
là on en parle donc effectivement et des
images qui reviennent et c'est ça a été
des moments des baux de bons moments
donc ça s'oublie pas vous y pensez
souvent merci
patricia kaas d'avoir réservé cette
première visite à notre journal je
rappelle le titre de cet album dont qui
sort demain dans 44 pays ça c'est un
vrai lancement international
bon ma chère patrie chacun merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rendu visite et
puis bonne chance pour ce cd et puis
pour la suite de votre carrière
merci voilà dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet avec du gris honore
printemps au sud erreur 20 missions de
nuit philippe lefait demain trésor
patrick chêne quant à moi je vous
retrouverai demain soir à 20 heures je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée
bonsoir